e
e e
War if you um I apologize for the delay
we had some technical difficulties if
you would please Jo rise and join me for
the Pledge of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stand one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
justice for
all e
okay I'm open to um the executive
session on House
Bill 59
and I understand there are some folks
here that came today for the executive
session on this bill um we are still
talking to a couple of other people or
um stakeholders that are in interested
in this bill and we were intending to
put it off until next week for the
vote oh I'm
sorry for the people that are here for
59 today I understand you were here for
an executive session to um endorse us
passing the bill if you wanted to
address US I'd be happy to hear from you
um our intent is to continue with that
uh Bill we are not um we're not killing
it or anything but we are talking to
other stakeholders that are interested
in the bill and I wanted to give them an
opportunity to be heard and I have not
had a chance to speak to them this week
so we will be recessing this bill until
next week for our final vote if you came
here today to address us or if you just
wanted to have anything to say I'd be
willing to hear from you or did you just
want to be here to kind of kind of moral
support type
thing
no okay very good all right um so with
nothing further than I'm going to uh
recess House Bill 59 to I believe what
was it next Wednesday
yeah with that I will open um executive
session on House Bill 87 and
recognize representative saor D sha for
a
motion I I skipped it on purpose for
House Bill 87 I motion ought to
pass represent
second second I go ahead I will second
that on second by representative lels um
discussion would you like to speak to
your motion representative yes this bill
prohibits the posting of land not owned
by the poster it's protecting of
property rights and individual should
not be posting on land that is not their
own thank you representative CS would
you like speak to you a second no that's
fine okay um I'll just add that this
this was brought um the issue is people
going hunting on land that's not posted
pulling up in their truck getting out
going into the woods coming back out
being called by the police and uh
meeting them out there to ask them why
they're hunting on poed property because
while they were out there someone
stapled up some no trespassing no
hunting posters turning out that it
wasn't really their property it's just
activists who don't like hunting um so
this would make it unlawful for someone
to post land like that if it's not their
property further
discussion representative um har gather
yes um I don't have a problem with the
bill but I do have a problem with the
actual um misdemeanor B um I would be
willing to take a look at it and maybe
do something like a violation of fine
than a
misdemeanor but to start off with a
misdemeanor B I have a problem with
that further
discussion given the um the given the
late uh date I do not anticipate um
waiting on that any any further
discussion see none I asked the clerk to
call the rooll the motion on the excuse
me oh representative
M I just want to say that I agree with
representative Harriet gaite um I think
that this uh penalty of Class B
misdemeanor uh is uh a little too severe
uh for something of this nature and uh a
violation level offense would be more
appropriate um the idea that somebody
might get a criminal record uh for what
could be a prank uh doesn't sit well
with me what doesn't sit well with me is
that some who's out there hunting will
be charged with a criminal offense for
trespassing or on posted property until
they can prove otherwise so um a prank
that could end up with someone with a
criminal charge in my mind should be uh
a similar a similar offense um with that
I'll ask clerk to call the RO motion of
floors ought to
pass Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative LEL yes
representative bogert yes represent
resentative Manion yes representative
tutor yes representative saborn dwan yes
representative klering yes
representative harri Gite no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes no representative Newell no
chairman Roy chair votes yes 96 96
motion carries um who's going to write
The Minority Report
representative here at gather if I could
have it by Sunday please um let me see
and representative so D you'll write the
majority in
that and with that I close the executive
session I open the executive session on
House Bill 245 and recognize
representative shabor D sha for a
motion I Motion in expedient to
legislate for 245 second seconded by
representative rhods would you like to
speak to your motion
yeah yes sir we do not need to establish
a second a separate fund for simply
speed
enforcement thank you would you like to
speak to your second that sounds
good I like it it's py
um any further
discussion seeing none ask clerk to call
the RO motion of floor is inexpedient to
legislate Vice chair rhs yes
representative PR yes representative Lal
yes representative bogert yes
representative Manion yes representative
tutor yes representative Sabor D Shier
yes representative K kesing yes
representative Harry gther no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes yes representative Newell no
representative oh chairman Roy cherot
yes um
10 yeah 10 10 10 five 105 uh motion
carries 105 who will write the uh
Minority
Report and representative d suborn d you
write the majority report correct yes
sir
and with that I close the executive
session I open the executive session on
House Bill 500 recognize representative
appr to make a motion I make a motion to
itl Second would you like to speak to
your
motion sure uh I don't think we need to
be telling the state police how to
patrol the highways they know where they
need to be and we don't need to be
setting up enhanced
zones that's all I got thank you would
you like to speak to you a
second no thank you any further
discussion uh this is
500 further discussion on
500 see a none I asked to call the role
the motion on the floor is inexpedient
to
legislate uh Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative LEL
yes representative bogert yes represent
representative Manion yes representative
tutor yes representative Sor deer yes
representative kering yes representative
Harry goite yes representative
Muse muse no yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes chairman Roy chair yes 15 15 0 any
objection to going on consent seeing
none it will go on consent and I hereby
close the executive session I open the
executive session on House Bill 109 and
recognize representative rhs to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move o to
pass second second by representative
appr would you like to speak to your
motion oh thank you Mr chairman um you
know if a if a person makes a false
report about a a police officer not only
does the officer have to you know go
through the the investigation process
now there is obviously a a an incredibly
black mark on their name um and not to
mention the expense of of it so this
would basically um create a misdemeanor
level if you make a knowingly make a
false report about misconduct of an
officer that you know that is
false would you like to speak to your
second representative
PR sure I believe right now there's no
penalty for making such a report uh and
I don't think people really grasp what a
report like that does to an officer in
his career his job he may be suspended
while the investigation's going on so
there needs to be a penalty for for
making a false report and I'm glad to
see we're finally getting to it thank
you I I would add that as we as we
mature as a society
um we've decided we're going to hold our
police officers to a higher standard and
I think that's justifiably so at the
same time we have to understand we are
in a partnership with law enforcement so
we must hold ourselves to that same high
standard so by making false reports
about someone knowingly and
intentionally um I feel like there
definitely should be some type of
societal answer to people that do that
because of the incredible um effect it
has on someone who's the subject of such
a report I believe someone famously once
said where do I go now to get my
reputation back um and and that's
absolutely correct because after the
investigation's done and the officer's
been cleared their names still out there
in the press for that allegation forever
um so I I think this is an important
bill further discussion representative
Harriet gather I have a question um can
you define misconduct versus criminal
conduct to us
please I've been trying to figure that
one out in this bill pres Manning would
you like to speak to
that yeah so when I initially filed the
bill missconduct would be anything
that's not criminal but um there was
some testimony about miss condic being
already defined in the statute uh for
the police standards and training
Council so that's different than
criminal activity so if you somebody
says that you use a racial slur or they
were rude to me or they they did
something else that was just
that that falls under those uh those
guidelines that would be misconduct if
somebody says they stole my money or
they assaulted me or they uh touch me
inappropriately that's criminal activity
that you're accusing the officer of so
there's two different distinctions there
obviously the the latter being more
serious I guess that that de matter that
depends on who's receiving that
information whether it's more serious or
not I would I would assume that no
matter who's hearing it it would be
criminals is more serious
one other question go ahead um how is
noly defined in law now in our laws I
couldn't find
that um knowingly yeah um I'm I'm pretty
sure I don't know that it's defined in
statute but it's defined by the court um
knowingly would mean that you had to
actually know for a fact that what you
were doing was um
incorrect be to Pro okay thank you very
much you're welcome chairman
yes with respect to knowingly the way I
think of it and I think that's the way
it is in law is it it's possible for
someone to make an accusation and make a
mistake in they they made a mistake but
knowingly doing it is different from
making a
mistake so that's how I took that you
know the
difference all right thank
you any further discussion did you want
to add on that uh representative Manion
on the knowingly thing yeah so there's
four coupable state of mind uh
negligently recklessly knowingly and
purposely so obviously they they go up
so purposely would be the most the
hardest to prove but if someone did
something negligently or recklessly they
still may be doing it knowingly but
that's less that's that's less to prove
so knowingly it's pretty it's a pretty
high standard to prove uh in court that
you did it with the with that intent
that you knew it was false but you did
it to uh whatever for Retribution
against the officer or whatnot so that's
the difference with
knowingly representative
M yeah I'm going to vote uh against this
bill I I think one of the big concerns
that I have with it is it could very
well discourage people uh from reporting
police misconduct in the first place um
we had some testimony uh from the state
police also that uh the uh sworn
falsification statute wouldn't apply if
these statements are not because these
statements aren't sworn and that another
statute deals with unsworn false
falsification uh so there may be overlap
between that statute uh and this one and
I think the the other thing we need to
realize is the power equation uh between
a citizen and between a police officer
um there are remedies for uh uh for
police officers who are unfairly accused
um there are processes in place I'm just
not sure that we need a law we need to
put a law like this into statute um at
this
time anything further see none I ask
Court to call the rooll motion on the
floor is ought to
pass Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative LEL yes
representative vurt yes representative
Manion yes representative tutor yes
representative saor D Shier yes
representative kering yes representative
Harry Gite no representative muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
oh chairman Roy chair votes yes 96 96
motion carries um again I'll need the
Minority Report named by the time we
finish um who made the motion
representative Roi do the majority
report on that um we
those with that I close the executive
session for which one we have an
amendment there should be an amendment
out for that um I open the executive
session hpit 143 should have received an
amendment um and I recognize
representative rhods to make a motion on
the amendment thank you Mr chairman um I
move ought to pass and offer Amendment
HH um I did ask uh representative Murphy
was helping me hand them out but then I
did have a little bit of a uh situation
with a drink does anyone need one does
everybody have it does everyone have the
amendment yeah I'm guessing by the blank
books yes okay um okay so anyway second
that motion that would be me I was
waiting okay representative approv
second um would you like to speak to
your motion on the amendment sure thank
you Mr chairman uh so this was the bill
that came before us about the no
trespass orders and the concern was not
that people should not be able to
receive a no trespass order it was the
fact that there was not any kind of a
process in place that if a person did
and when we heard testimony there were
some questions asked um you know when
when when one of these these trespass
orders is given is there also something
given that tells them what the process
would be to have this removed or how
long this is going to be in effect the
answer was no so uh the sponsor did hear
some of the concerns we had with the way
the bill was written uh the amendment in
front of you is basically a replace all
and it actually gives a process for
person if they do receive one um it
talks about the ability to request a
hearing um it does have in here you know
also some safeguards for the person that
is that is issuing the no trespass order
in other words if if you receive a no
trespass order and you you know you
violate that and you get another no
trespass order within two years um
they're actually able to have it have
that no trespass order B for one year um
it also gives them the ability to extend
it for 90 days if they see fit but more
importantly it gives a process for the
person that received it and it will be
clearly outlined what the process is for
them if they receive the they receive
it expect to speak to your second
representative I think she covered it
quite well and I but I would add that
there definitely needs to be a way and
people have the knowledge to know that
the no trespass order can be revoked uh
at some point in time thank you
representative rhs I know that there
were some questions about how um how it
would be appealed and the in the
original bill I think it said something
about like they had to be unanimous or
or so has that all been
addressed Mr chair there is a there is a
process in here for the the appealing
and if you give me a second I can find
the um yeah the exact
line
um line 15 so if you if you look at the
very first part like on line8 it starts
to talk about it and then on line 15 it
talks about requesting the hearing and
then it goes on that's where it goes on
to say how they can be extended um
however they can also be
revoked okay and it takes now uh 23ds
under this versus a unanimous vote of
the
body which is what I was um trying to
figure
out thank you further discussion line 17
y representative Harry GTH yes um I am
going to vote against this bill um I do
truly believe that it does interfere
with our 14 Amendment rights and also
right now today that's handled by um the
city or the town and I don't believe
that we as the state body should be
interfering with this
situation thank you further discussion
represent
M yeah um as always uh thank thank you
for giving us these amendments uh you
know right as we're starting executive
sessions but uh in my my quick read of
this and my comparison of some of the
testimony that we received earlier on
this bill um is that this amendment does
not address the concerns that were
raised during the public hearing um
uh one of the things that uh uh one of
the things that we heard uh the New
Hampshire School Board Association uh uh
testify to is that the um that uh the
school board or public body should not
have to hold uh an an additional meeting
uh for the purpose of the hearing that
it can be held during the next regularly
scheduled meeting this amendment does
not appear to do that the vote is by a
public uh Body by a simple majority this
requires a 2third super majority there
is no uh the School Board Association
requested uh no appeal to Superior Court
uh there is appeal to Superior Court in
this um so you know I I think having
guard rails around some of this is a is
is a good idea but I think this needs it
really does need some additional work
given the the fact that virtually no one
I don't think anybody aside from the
sponsor testified in favor of this bill
um and the amendment that we have is
from the same sponsor and it doesn't
address the concerns that were raised in
the
hearing thank you I I would say that the
concerns were raised only by the school
board and um our caucus doesn't work for
the school board so we're going to go
ahead and vote without it I would
disagree so I would go ahead and the
director of theing I didn't ask you to
you will not speak until I allow you to
speak I did not recognize you to speak
thank you with that I would ask the
clerk to call the role the motion on the
floor is ought to
pass or adoption of the amendment Vice
chair rhs yes representative PR betcha
representative lels yes representative
bogert yes representative Manion yes
representative tutor yes representative
Sabor dhir yes representative kesslering
yes representative Harry Gite no
representative
Muse representative Newman no
representative Murphy no the clerk votes
yes representative
no representative or chairman Roy chair
yes uh 105 what 105 10 five motion
carries executive session on that bill
is
closed we will be in recess for 15
minutes
right are the pass as
amended so contining vote
143 I recognize representative rhs to
make a motion thank you Mr chair I move
ought to pass as amended for 143 second
moved and seconded for discussion seeing
none clerical call the rooll a pass is
amended thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to State for the other members of the
caucus that the sponsor did send this to
Chairman Roy chair rhs and myself on
Wednesday and I didn't realize that
other members of the committee weren't
copied on that email so I apologize for
not forwarding that on to others um but
I do believe the sponsor has shown good
faith in trying to address some of the
concerns that we have and I hope if this
bill makes it to the Senate that any
further adjustments can be made if
they're
necessary thank
you Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative St yes
representative bogert yes representative
Manion yes representative tutor yes
representative saor dhir yes
representative kesing yes representative
Harriet gther no representative muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes yes
representative Newell no chairman Roy
yes
105 metic close the session all right
we're still in recess till um quarter
up
e
e e
Mr chairman if I just may make a
um if if I may there is the amendment
that we were waiting for for house spill
62 which is why it was not open first
thing this morning um but it is on its
way around we were able to just get this
from OS so thank you
for the benefit of the people that are
here I'm opening House Bill uh 59
executive session just to let you know
that we will be recessing it until next
Wednesday as we work on language so
thank you for
coming um with that I open the executive
session on House Bill
62 and recognize myself for a motion
to introduce um amendment number 0282 H
second this amendment is brought after
discussions of stakeholders the um
Coalition and the Department of Defense
um went over this language and requested
the amendment um basically nothing's
changed this just makes it so
that military protective orders are
admissible in our
proceedings towards getting as evidence
towards another protective order in the
Civil Court would you like to speak to
your second no thank you further
discussion on House Bill 6 to amendment
number 282
H representative Harry
G since this is replacing that can you
give us a moment just read through
it it's replacing what was originally
given to us
sure thank
you for
I'm good if everybody else
is
for e
this
isn't the problem that I'm having with
this is where do we draw that line I
wrote myself notes because I mean I'm
probably going to say yes would but I'm
struggling with it because you Dro a
line between the local government and
federal government so today we don't
want no federal government in things
then now we get something now we say yes
we went
that
e
e e
um might ask the clerk to call the rooll
Motions to about to passes Amendment
Vice chair Roes yes representative PR
yes representative LEL yes
representative bogert yes representative
Manion yes representative tutor yes
representative saor desier yes
representative kesing yes representative
Harry gther representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes chairman Roy chair votes yes
160 160 any objection to consent seeing
none go consent hereby close the
executive session um that I open the
executive session
on House Bill
640 and recognize representative subor D
to make a motion yes my motion is off to
pass second seconded by representative
Ro you like to speak to your motion yes
government efficiency is the the word of
the day and I think we'd all be very
interested in finding out exactly what
our federal what the federal government
is do in our
state thank you representative Ro you
like to speak to your second no thank
you any further
discussion representative here at
GA no um when I look at this I I I'm
really struggling with it to be honest
with you um and then I looked at the
cost to the state with possibly three
positions and from my understanding
um we're struggling with the budget as
it is um I don't think that I can vote
for this
so I'm going to say no to this one I
can't accept it thank you um I also was
concerned about the cost however um we
are a policy committee and I believe
that they're going to have to figure out
the whether or not that that's an
accurate estimate I I just I find it
difficult to wrap my mind around needing
basically an entire Legal Office office
just to collect the documents of what
the federal government's doing as far as
law enforcement in our state to pass it
on to us um but I I'll leave that to
finance to figure out between them and
the um Department of Justice
representative Murray thank you chairman
um yeah I agree that um I would love to
know everything the federal government
is doing in our state I do think um the
quarterly reports is maybe where it gets
a little too um over burdening to the
AG's office especially we're trying not
to supply um more staff there um just
because of the time considering the
amount of um divisions there are that
they would have to reach out to and that
we have no control over where they're
over whether they're going to respond or
not so having the AG's office have to go
through this whole like RMA rule every 3
months I think um could potentially be
too much to start with I feel like if
this was like every six months or once a
year I would be more likely to support
it but um I like the the thought the
idea
behind thank you further discussion
representative
Muse one of the reasons I'm going to
vote against this bill is I'm not 100%
sure what it actually accomplishes um
this is information that I already that
I understand is already published by the
federal government um it seems to just
put an unnecessary burden on the
Attorney General's office and an
unnecessary burden that costs money in a
budget year um and I think the other
thing uh that I notice as a frequent
user of virtually all of our agency
websites is uh one of the hardest things
to do in the state of New Hampshire is
to find anything on any of our agency
websites and if I was to invest
$200,000 um uh in in uh improving the
experience of of V ERS uh uh in this
state on our agency websites I would put
it into some uh web design and feedback
on and how to make it easier to use and
one thing I might do is actually put in
a usable search engine which none of our
agency websites seem to have so the
bottom line is there are heck of a lot
better ways to spend
$250,000 than on uh uh information
that's already there thank you
representative
Newman yeah I just have a question about
uh line number five that says the
Attorney General shall formally request
that the federal government and agencies
with law
enforcement uh investigatory and
operational activities
voluntarily provide the following
aggregated data and what happens if the
uh federal government just does not
voluntarily do that I'm not sure what
this bill
says happens then well I don't think
anything happens I don't think we can
make the federal government do anything
I think what this would bill would do is
um mandate our attorney general to ask
the federal government if the federal
government says no Then the answer is
no further discussion representative
share uh it's a combination of the cost
understanding that Finance hopefully
will sort that out combination of the
cost and having some body let's assume
the cost is validated having someone's
every 3 months uh ask the federal
government for X Y and Z all the
agencies and them saying not even
responding I
just I like I very much like the idea
but I just I'm just not sure it's worth
the cost assuming the cost is
valid I assume the answer would probably
be more along the lines of what
representative Newman thinks it's going
to be and there would be no cost because
there'd be no information forthcoming
yeah I think I think the the the problem
is they're still required to find all
the agencies operating in the state and
sending the letter out so that they can
collect the non-answer that and that
just seems a waste of time further
discussion see none motion on the floor
is ought to pass ask the cour to call
the
RO Vice chair roads yes representative
PR
uh yeah representative LEL yes what is
that representative bogert yes
representative Manion yes representative
Tudor yes representative saor D yes
representative kesslering yes
representative Harry goth no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes no representative Newell no
representative Shear no Roy chald CH 97
97 motion carries again Minority Report
today please uh you could tell me who's
doing it and who made this motion
representative saor D will have the
majority report um with that I close the
executive
session and what else do we have
anything
I'm opening executive session on house
bill9 for the purposes of advising the
public that there's yet um language work
being done in this bill and will be re
opened and taken up again next
Wednesday I am opening executive session
on House Bill
592 relative to magistrates and Bale and
similarly that one is currently being
worked on for language purposes and once
that's ready we will readdress it next
Wednesday and what
else is there any other I have to reopen
146 I already did right no that's body
camera that's
body executive session on 146 for the
use of body warn cameras that one is
also going to be held over to next
Wednesday um as there is another
amendment coming on that
one and mine which
one I did 159 didn't I just say 159 I
didn't
yeah yeah
okay 621 CER you just open I just did
that 162 you did 146 oh so
146 yeah what about 162 we did
162 didn't we just do it
ex yeah
exactly we just did
did 62 we did
62 that's your what
is searches of houses yeah we didn't do
that one yet yeah all right so with that
I'm opening executive session on House
Bill 162 and I would be happy to rep um
recognize representative Sher for a
motion I move out to pass I second would
you like to speak to your motion uh yes
this is a um uh
six or seven years ago the uh the
legislature passed a bill in which uh
somebody who stopped his car is stopped
by the police and uh the police asked
for the consent to search the car uh
they needed to inform the person that
they did not had a constitutional right
not to consent and uh that wouldn't be
used against them uh and if they agreed
to consent they would have to sign a
form that's been in place for I want to
say six or seven years uh I've heard no
reports of any problems with that this
simply expands that to include searches
of houses and other property with the
same procedure uh it's uh it's really at
this point just a matter of uh tweaking
the form that's already in place I've
talked with the chief in in uh Portsmith
and he said they've they were already
doing it any anyway and they've had no
problems with the
process thank you I I seem to remember
that bill you were talking about um
can't remember if I think I might have
actually wrote that bill is that the one
we're talking about I'm sorry the the
bill you were referencing from six or
seven years ago that's the one that I I
wrote that didn't I you did okay thank
you you and Senator French that's right
um and I I think this is anytime we can
use the government more more for
educational purpos purp than than
enforcement purposes or both at the same
time we should so by having law
enforcement remind people of their
rights um I in my opinion is not a bad
thing um especially when it comes to
searching their their most private areas
of their house and things of that nature
further
discussion seeing none I'd ask the cler
to call the role the motion on the floor
is ought to
pass Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative LEL yes
representative bogert yes representative
Manion yes representative tutor yes
representative saborn dniir yes
representative kesing yes representative
harri
gther yes representative
Muse yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative shear yes chairman Roy
chot yes 160 160 any objection to
consent see a none we'll go on consent
and that ends the executive
session before we wrap up is there any
other business that anyone can think of
that we have not handled that we should
be
handling or anything anyone thinks we
should exact because that we
can which one
for
what
that the bill that increases standards
for
the oh that's your bill yeah
have Rel to
thees
no yeah I'll show you the
am but we have to we have to come at
1:00 for this
relative driving while talk wait a
minute isn't that my bill mm that's one
you you scheduled to one: I didn't copy
that that's but I know there were two
yeah no I got that yeah yeah
yeah but this but but I
believe I believe that was recessed to
be opened at 1:00 for Terry what Terry
did talk about okay we're in uh we're
going to be H recess till 1:00
e
e e
um real quickly I'm opening the public
hearing on House Bill 776 you want to
testify on it no I I do not want to add
anything that wasn't already added I
appreciate you for holding it over for
me and with that I will close public
hearing we're done
okay we already did
it we actually
did
e
e e